une à la viande une sans viande c'est à
s'y méprendre c'est des produits pour
lesquels les gens sont assez
conservateur en général on est habitué à
une forme une texture particulière très
difficile de nous faire changer d'avis
quand on les regarde et quand on y goûte
c'est vraiment très très similaires les
saucisses sont un des premiers aliments
pour lesquels une alternative végétale a
été développée et vj et de loin la
marque on connaît le plus marque locale
fondée en 1985 qui n'ont pas été les
premiers à nous faire découvrir le vg
avec la saucisse une dizaine de marques
offrent maintenant plus d'une
quarantaine de choix de ce site vend du
dans tous les grands supermarchés
llyod des différences énormes en matière
de composition d'abord et avant tout on
a certains produits comme les goûts ce
cas par exemple qu'on peut qualifier
davantage d'artisanal s'est fait avec
peu d'ingrédients les ingrédients
simples même chose avec à l'horizon un
des ingrédients qui sont en dessous par
contre on a plusieurs de nos
échantillons qui sont ce que j'oserais
appelé des aliments technologique c'est
à dire qu'ils ont demandé et qui demande
beaucoup techno beaucoup manipulation on
est tellement loin des ingrédients
d'origine quand on arrive dans le
produit fini que honnêtement je n'ai
aucune idée comment est ce que le corps
gers commentait ce qu'il absorbe ce
c'est ça des jeunes il fumait ou de
style européenne elles ont longtemps été
faites avec du soya mais aujourd'hui on
en trouve aussi à base de farine de
gluten de poids iman de gourgas
comme pour les sociétés traditionnelles
à la viande il ya trois nutriments clés
qui valent la peine de jeter un oeil
dessus pour comparer et faire les bons
choix des protéines le gras et le sodium
on s'en sort pas c'est vraiment leur
salle face 15 g de protéines c'est pas
mal notre barème minimum pour considérer
que ça commençait drame en nourrissant
donc non plus protéines et sont la gamme
européenne de filles trust où on a 26 28
grammes de protéines ensuite very good
butcher sa saucisse britannique au 24
gramme de protéine et du côté de iv dit
deux nouveaux produits on est autour de
24 25 grammes par saucisse avec isabelle
on les a analysés et en compagnie du
chef du restaurant végétarien dollars ca
on ya aussi goûter merci
pour commencer la journée 3 saucisses à
déjeuner de marques différentes
ça sent la cannelle c'est pas du tout
dans les références que je me fais d'une
société avait jamais en termes de
textures et peu de goût non plus j'ai
envie de dire on est plus proche soit
textures un peu d'un 10 km où j'ai
l'impression de manger un sablier
granuleux et si cris la texture est
vraiment différente là on est très
proche d'une texture de de viande c'est
compliqué de faire des bonnes csbj mais
c'est comme dans n'importe quelle c'est
l'essai de l'erreur ce qu'on peut faire
c'est proposer aux consommateurs un
produit qui est le plus possible le
produit de la viande plusieurs produits
sont faites au canada des saucisses
gustave fontaine santé sont
confectionnés au québec tout comme libé
jeet on regarde les produits carnés
qu'est ce que les gens préfèrent on
regarde plus revendeurs et puis
finalement ce qu'on se rend compte c'est
que l'une servant très particulière
italienne douce qui le produit le plus
populaire dans les saucisses ya une
prédominance de fenouillet à l'intérieur
c'est ce qu'on va venir imiter à
l'intérieur de notre pression mais
william jay walker le mettre sous sicié
s'est lancé dans l'aventuré du végétal à
la demande de ses clients maintenant on
a quatre variétés qui roule qui sont un
complément aux contours de ce 6e de
viande
on est bien content qu'est-ce que vous
avez choisi comme frotter c'est une
protéine de base de soya parfois le
mélange de base pour le masquer le mp il
faut y ajouter un peu de goût et le sel
certes très bien comme barnes à ce
niveau c'est un produit qui n'a pas de
goyon ça fait partie des défis pour
arriver à quelque chose d'assez ferme
qu'on puisse mettre sur le barbecue
grillé et que ça tient la route bon ben
alors on passe au dîner
pour le dîner on a goûté à 306 de type
hot dogs au moins dans un pain avec du
ketchup et de la moutarde c'est réglé on
n'y voit que du feu par exemple c'est
vraiment une copie très réussie des
saucisses à hot dog thibout de fumée
très agréable
la société adobe on a des références
gustative qui nous suivent depuis notre
enfance qui on n'a pas trop envie
compromis quand on est dans cet univers
la salle est presque chacun pour les
papilles le goût serait dommage et est
couvert à lecelles plutôt désolant la
plupart des sociétés des jets sont
autant il parfois même plus à l'est que
cela la viande
on a une moyenne sur les 44 produits
qu'on a évalué de 480 mg de sodium par
portion mon moins salée en a 200 mon
plus aller en à 790 c'est la fièvre aux
fumées qui se trouve être de loin elle a
pu saler belle surprise l'ensemble des
saucisses à hot-dog de yves et jean font
très bonne figure aussi avec les taux de
sodium qui sont autour de 2,5 à m'en
veux terminer les dégustations avec et
les saucisses italiennes couleurs très
appétissante vraiment voir les herbes
les as roma qui ressorte la famille est
intéressant on sent les graines entières
là j'aime beaucoup ça les stresse un peu
mais c'est un must pour les saucisses
italiennes
en général les alternatives végétales
sont moins grasse l'avantagé en fait et
surtout au niveau du gras saturés dans
des saucisses régulière ou en fait les
saucisses de viande gras saturés aussi
en moyenne autour de 6 grammes alors que
dans les échantillons qu'on avait notre
moyenne et à 1,3 g donc une nette
différence les deux seuls produits pour
lequel on a des teneur en gras saturés
qui sont similaires voire même
légèrement supérieure à ce qu'on
retrouve dans la viande c'était
surprenant mais c'est les produits de
végéter de billets en mythe qui utilise
de l'huile de coco donc l'huile de coco
qui est naturellement riche en gras
saturés vieille augmenté malheureusement
se chiffrera là où ça surprend le plus
c'est dans le prix dans l'ensemble les
saucisses végétales sont plus chers que
les produits à base de viande c'est
difficile d'en sortir un gagnant parce
que souvent c'est gagnant sur une valeur
pas sur l'autre cela dit je ne serai
quand même pas porté à recommander à
dire il mettait ce sont battables tous
les jours non
les faire maison pas si compliqué sa
demande juste un peu de persévérance
alors la première étape on va faire
sauter les échalotes un peu d'ail et un
petit peu de l'enlever on va mettre ça à
refroidir pendant qu'on prépare le reste
on a de la poudre d'ail la poudre
d'oignons du paprika fumé la farine de
gluten
et là on reprend nos échalas qui ont peu
refroidi faut quand même que ce soit h
et à ses fins parce que sinon la
saucisse doit pas se tenir moi je mets
un peu de gras dans les saucisses pour
qu'elles soient plus goûteuse bouillon
de légumes sauce soja c'est vraiment la
texture qui est très difficile à avoir
en fait retrouvé le bon équilibre entre
la farine de gluten de protéines de blé
qu'on utilise et le liquide se joue à
quelques grammes près parce que trop de
liquide s'affaire une texture vraiment
molle
la texture est impeccable
c'est très proches de ceux ci devient
certain qu'on pourrait convaincre des
carnivores d'essayer à l'occasion des
saucisses végétales c'est savoureux en
goûte très bien les aromates bravo c'est
réussi merci